So one of the really exciting new things that you guys have recently put into
CUDA is this idea of dynamic parallelism, and so we've had some material on that in the course.
So before we talk about what it actually is, can you talk about what problem you're trying to solve?
&gt;&gt; The thing we really want to do, at least, the way that I think about it,
the thing that I want to be able to do with the GPU is to make it easier to program
and to broaden the number of problems you can do on the GPU.
so the GPU starts out being really, really good at very broad bulk parallelism.
You can throw a lot of threads at a problem. It handles them very efficiently, but for less regular problems,
for more sort of diverse or fine grain parallelism,
it's hard to express that in CUDA today.
So the dynamic parallelism effort was to try and aim at an easier way
to extract more parallelism from your problem.
So we wanted to solve the kinds of problems, things like recursion, things like task parallelism,
those types of problems that are difficult to express in a single big grid of threads,
sort of paradigm, we might want to enable new types of programming problems to be solved.